It's time, for the ultimate reboot:
Batmans versus Spider-Mans.
(laughter)
Starring Tobey Maguire,
Andrew Garfield, Tom Holland,
Michael Keaton, Val Kilmer,
George Clooney, Christian Bale,
Ben Affleck, Lego Batman,
no, Chris O'Donnell, and CGIed Adam West.
(audience laughter and cheering)
Also starring nipples, no nipples,
next to no nipples, a hint of nipples,
hey, where'd the nipples go?
And I kind of miss the nipples.
With a special appearance by
Pink Ranger Amy Jo Johnson,
Catherine Sutherland, Patricia Ja Lee,
Valerie Vernon, Alison MacInnis,
Erin Cahill, Alycia Purrott, Angie Diaz,
Rhoda Montemayor, Erika
Fong, Christina Masterson,
Camille Hyde, and Naomi Scott.
And product placement by the 1981 McRib,
1985 McRib, 1989 McRib,
1992 McRib, 1995 McRib,
2002 McRib, 2005 McRib,
2010 McRib, 2012 McRib,
2014 McRib, and the 2016 McRib.
All of them presented by Willard Scott,
George Voorhis, Ken Horsman, Jack Doepke,
David Hussey, John
Wartheim, Roger Sezylinkski,
Bradley Rickson, Francis X.
Goodrich, and Brad Lennon.
And don't forget to enjoy this movie
with the help of these Zoloft Generics:
Zolit, Zosert, Zoltral,
Diazipan, Medisol, Altisben,
Serlain, Serlift, and Sertalix.
Batmans versus Spidermans.
Coming every two years
for the rest of your life.
(audience applauding and cheering)
We'll never run out.